hey guys it's vadim with max tech and in
this video i'm gonna be doing something
that i have never done before
gaming on a foldable phone yes this is
the galaxy z fold 3 and i am extremely
excited for this because i'm going to be
playing games like call of duty mobile
gentian impact and league of legends
wild rift to see if there are any
advantages to owning a foldable phone
for gaming and how much better it is
compared to the iphone 12 pro max so
without further ado let's go ahead and
get right into call of duty mobile but
first i want to quickly shout out our
m1x chip design t-shirts which you can
check out in the merge shelf below this
video so just so i have a benchmark
refresh in my brain i'm gonna replay
call of duty mobile on my iphone and
then play it on the galaxy fold to see
how big of a difference there is and i
do want to mention that the fold does
support 120 hertz but i am not going to
be playing in that refresh rate just so
it's pretty fair between the two but as
we know the iphone 13 pro max is coming
very soon and it is going to be having
120 hertz so keep that in mind all right
so as we can see in the graphics
settings i have the frame rate set to
max graphics quality set to very high
and we're going to match that on the z
full 3. real-time shadows we'll leave it
on water reflections ragdoll whatever
let's just turn this crazy stuff on
actually depth of field no let's just do
it like like this yeah gun game mosh pit
there you go oh one thing i forgot to
mention is that i've made the brightness
on both of these phones equal at around
80 percent brightness so they're
matching just to see if there's any
differences in maybe overheating or
display dimming because we have
experienced that before with the iphone
of course we have the oh
i was gonna say we've got the notch
that is very annoying stews are
everywhere man
get out of here bro
i will survive man
oh are you serious oh still got him yeah
the notch is a little annoying of course
but it is going to be getting smaller so
keep that in mind
dude you guys suck oh
he got me
you can't see that bro
get out of here oh you suck man
easy
oh
oh got him
got him and knife last one
oh serious bro
okay that was a bad kill cam
couldn't let it happen like that
oh man dude whatever i suck that's fine
oh a little bit glitchy i don't know why
but all right so far performance
perfectly smooth as we'd expect with the
a13 at least towards the end it kind of
gets glitchy as soon as you kill someone
with the killcam but hey perfect
performance everything's great
no complaints with the iphone except
obviously the notch which is gonna get
smaller which is awesome and with that
said i'm gonna go ahead and switch over
to the z fold three to see how the
experience changes all right and here we
are on the z full three and man
that is a big
immersive
display and that's awesome how the
aspect ratio at least in the ui
is nice let's go ahead go to the
graphics settings max out the frame rate
graphics quality very high turn on these
settings right here just like we did for
the other one nice for some reason the
quality seems like it's i don't know not
perfect almost like it's kind of yeah
it's definitely not sharp like the names
aren't sharp interesting all right guys
this is weird it almost seems like it's
zoomed in because the quality does not
look as good as the iphone
whoa
i feel like it moves differently kind of
hard to explain
let's see if i could still win though
yeah it's almost like the sensitivity of
the display is kind of odd
yeah the way the like the display moves
is just kind of odd man i honestly like
don't like it
like the iphone's display
moves nicely but this is just kind of
weird and the knife and the knife
well i mean i still did really well
first place
totally owned everybody but i feel like
i don't know if it's like the display
protector film that's on here or just
the sensitivity it feels kind of weird
can't explain it but man this display is
definitely immersive but it kind of
feels like the sides of the screen are
kind of chopped off almost like it crops
in
so you can't really see as much yeah see
that it's almost like it's cropping in
like these people should be fully in
frame but in terms of like seeing stuff
on the screen like this is so much more
immersive like look at that
super immersive and we do have that
under display camera right there like
you literally can barely tell
right there yeah so definitely more
immersive at least in call of duty but
the text is not that sharp that's my one
complaint and i feel like it does crop
in
and it cuts out like your side vision
which is annoying but i mean what do you
expect it's like a very square-ish
aspect ratio so let's go ahead and go
back to the iphone all right we're back
on the iphone league of legends wild
riff right here we're in the graphics
settings let's go ahead and set it to
performance 60fps
that's for sure we want to do that and i
think that's the only change we really
want to make
let's get into a game
oh i missed him
get him bros come on man
oh
oh oh
i still got him though
suck it alright so obviously no
complaints with the iphone 12 pro max so
far perfect 60fps i haven't noticed any
drops at all
so no glitches nothing dude kill the
rift hill bro
got it
[Music]
get rekt
oh no
honestly i do feel like the display on
the iphone is a little bit limiting
because like all the characters are
pretty small
all the icons everything have to be
small so it's definitely limiting in
terms of the display size even though
this is the 12 pro max you know you
wouldn't really think about it
[Music]
you guys said that
nice
all right am i oh quadra cool
oh stop all right guys this is it
get him
oh
i couldn't fit a pet to kill dude
all right boys let's go it's our time to
shine
go go go go go quickly
yeah
all right we got to back up i got it
back up that's for sure
got him
we going for this guy let's go let's do
it
whoa
oh
[Laughter]
and update ah come on man oh this ezreal
is so good man look at him
oh is he gonna oh is he dude just pen to
kill him bro you got it
oh
we won there you go i mean the iphone
is pretty good for gaming i've gotta
admit but i'm very excited to see how
that massive screen on the z-fold three
is gonna be so let's check it out all
right guys i'm very surprised and
impressed by the scaling and aspect
ratio like in this game look we've got
garen right here perfectly filling up
the frame all the ui
awesome for this more squarish aspect
ratio it's actually really nice so
wow now i'm in the graphics settings and
i'm going to set it to the same
performance 60 fps as i did
on the iphone and let's go ahead and get
into a game and one thing i do want to
mention is that the little crease in the
folds display hasn't bothered me at all
i do kind of see it with the light
reflection but
honestly it still looks great super
sharp
ui controls
feel great wow this display man is
colorful
[Music]
whoa dude this is too easy man easy
yes
this is so fun
oh chill bro
hey
got him 12 to 0 right now this is too
easy
dude how did you survive that all right
now watch this watch this guys
legendary
oh he killed him
dude what about a penta kill
20
to zero
not a single drop frame that i've seen
so far
it's not overheating oh dude can i like
run
i just died
please
oh
get
wrecked bro good game 30 kills to one
death are you available
dimming the screen literally dimmed as
soon as i got into the game that's what
sucks about
the iphone 12 lineup i don't know if
it's the a14 ship or it's just this
crazy game which is super
graphics intensive man
compared to other games
it's insane but what i want to show you
guys is the graphics settings so let's
go over here i don't even have
everything maxed out so let's just go
highest current performance load is too
high which can lead to overheating blah
blah blah it dimmed again guys look how
dark
this display is and i'm literally
feeling some dropped frames now that is
not okay like it is overheating the
display is pretty bright at like 80
percent but still man you shouldn't have
to deal with this on a flagship iphone
like look at how dim i can feel the heat
on this phone it is insane man
wow
boom
oh there you go look it just got
brighter now let's see how long this'll
last
honestly i don't think it'll last long
but
oh look it was kind of dim because now
it's a little brighter that's
interesting yeah that's nice and bright
i am getting dropped frames just like
you guys saw right there alright so
while we did have some pretty bad
dimming as soon as i turned this game on
over time it did kind of recover and now
the display is looking nice and bright
even though the graphics settings are
basically on the highest
so i'm pretty happy about that but still
i did experience some frame drops and
that crazy dimming
so now
let's go ahead and see
how it runs
on the z fold three all right and here
we are on the z fold three i've got the
settings maxed out just like i had on
the iphone
and let's go ahead and check out how it
does and if it
dims or not
yeah so even with this aspect ratio
everything's perfect
i don't notice that hole punch at all
so they did a good job with that ui
feels great
boom easy peasy bro no seriously no
dimming
pop pop then you go like this and go
yeah no issues at all everything works
perfect yeah i'm actually really really
impressed
with the galaxy z43 so there you guys go
there was gaming on both of these phones
and let's finish off with my conclusion
well for call of duty mobile i honestly
preferred the iphone because you get
that widescreen view you see more
enemies on the sides compared to the
fold which seems to kind of crop in and
because of the squarish aspect ratio you
can't really see those enemies and like
the touch sensitivity was being kind of
weird so i prefer the iphone for that
but honestly
everything other than that especially
league of legends wild rift that was
amazing
on the fold because the text was sharp
everything looked beautiful gameplay no
issues at all and it was just so
immersive you don't have to deal with
that notch and the under display camera
i didn't even notice that little grid or
anything at all it was just such a good
experience and finally for gentian
impact the iphone had major thermal
throttling issues where the display
would dim down and it would overheat
causing a really bad gaming experience
but the fold was perfect no issues at
all no dimming great performance
immersive display so with that said and
with all that gaming done
i've got to say that
the galaxy x3
is now
my favorite gaming phone ever
and i think i'm gonna say that it's the
best gaming phone ever made so hopefully
you guys enjoy this video and if you did
go ahead and click the circle about to
subscribe definitely check out one of
our shirts down in the merch shelf below
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]